THANK SENATE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION WILL COME TO ORDER,
GOOD MORNING AGAIN. AND GOOD
MORNING TO JULIE IN MISSOURI,
THERE ARE 25 BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. 18 BILLS ARE IN CONSENT.
THEY ARE AS FOLLOWS. ITEM NUMBER
ONE, AB 801. ITEM NUMBER TWO, AB
2932. ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB 2567.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB 1913. ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB 2961. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB 1929. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB 1938. ITEM NUMBER 11 AB 2073.
ITEM NUMBER 14 AB 2251. ITEM
NUMBER 15 AB 2275. TO MY NEXT
PAGE OF ITEMS. ITEM NUMBER 16 AB
2707. ITEM NUMBER 17 AB 2725.
ITEM NUMBER 18 AB 2370. ITEM
NUMBER 20 AB 2403. ITEM NUMBER
21 AB 2429. ITEM NUMBER 22 ACR
147. ITEM NUMBER 23 AB 2771 AND
LAST ITEM NUMBER 25 AB 3290. WE
WILL BE STARTING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM, WELCOME TO SENATOR
JONES, WHO IS FILLING IN TODAY
FOR SENATOR OCHOA. BOGH AND WE
ARE LOOKING FOR AN AUTHOR TO
HELP YOU MAKE GOOD DECISIONS.
THANK YOU. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HEARD, BUT HE'S BEEN SENT TO
HELP US, MAKE US GOOD, MAKE HELP
US MAKE GOOD DECISIONS. I
APPRECIATE THAT. OKAY, AND SO
OUR FIRST ITEM IS FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS TO BE PRESENTED BY
SENATOR WILK, WHO IS ON HIS WAY.
I WILL ALSO SAY, IF YOU'RE AN
AUTHOR WITH BUSINESS IN FRONT OF
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY, YOU'D BE
WELL SERVED TO HEAD ON DOWN. WE
HAVE ONE, TWO, THREE, FOUR,
FIVE, SIX SEVEN BILLS THAT WE'LL
BE HEARING.
ALL RIGHT. AS THEY SAY, THE
FORMER EDUCATOR GETS THE WORM.
SO WELCOME, SENATOR QUIRK-SILVA,
IT'S SO NICE TO SEE YOU. AND
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING AB 2137,
AND WE'RE WE ARE CURRENTLY
MEETING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. IN
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. AND YOU
MAY BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
ALL RIGHT. WELL, I AM VERY HAPPY
TO BE HERE IN THIS, EDUCATION
CHAMBER WITH MY FAVORITE SENATOR
FROM FULLERTON, QUALIFIED IT IT
FELT GOOD FOR A SECOND. WE
QUALIFIED IT. GOOD MORNING. AND
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB 2137,
WHICH IMPROVES OUTCOMES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER YOUTH AND
STUDENTS WHO EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS BY UTILIZING
EXISTING RESOURCES TO ENHANCE
DIRECT STUDENT SUPPORT,
STREAMLINE COLLABORATION OF
SERVICES, AND REDUCE GAPS IN
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS.
THÀNH APPLICATION COMPLETION A
2019 CALIFORNIA AUDIT
HIGHLIGHTED THE STATE'S FAILURE
TO SERVE ITS STUDENTS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
ANNUALLY, ROUGHLY 225,000 K-12
STUDENTS ARE IDENTIFIED AS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND AN
ADDITIONAL 46,000 ARE IN FOSTER
CARE. RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THESE
STUDENTS FACE IMMENSE CHALLENGES
IN ATTAINING A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA AND SUCCESSFULLY
MATRICULATING TO HIGHER
EDUCATION, FOSTER AND HOMELESS
STUDENTS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY MORE
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE SCHOOL
INSTABILITY, CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
, SUSPENSIONS, AND EXPULSIONS.
BASICALLY, THESE OUTCOMES ARE
VERY POOR FOR THESE STUDENTS,
AND THIS IS WHY THIS BILL IS
VERY IMPORTANT WITH ME TODAY. WE
IN SUPPORT, WE HAVE PAIGE CLARK,
SENIOR PROGRAM AND POLICY
MANAGER WITH NATIONAL YOUTH LAW,
AND WEDNESDAY HOPE, STUDENT
ADVOCATE AND RECENT GRADUATE OF
FOLSOM LAKE COMMUNITY COLLEGE,
WELCOME TO BOTH THE WITNESSES.
PLEASE PROCEED. EACH WITNESS
WILL HAVE THREE MINUTES. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
PAIGE CLARK, AND I'M WITH THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW, A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2137. AB
2137 INCLUDES THREE COMMON SENSE
PROVISIONS THAT REMOVE
EDUCATIONAL BARRIERS FOR TWO OF
THE MOST DISADVANTAGED GROUPS
WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S K-12 SYSTEM
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE AND THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. FIRST, THIS BILL
WILL REMOVE AN OUTDATED
PROVISION THAT LIMITS WHETHER
COUNTY BASED EDUCATION PROGRAMS
CAN PROVIDE CRUCIAL SUPPORTS TO
FOSTER YOUTH, ALLOWING THESE
PROGRAMS TO OFFER DIRECT
SERVICES WILL ENSURE THAT MORE
FOSTER YOUTH HAVE ACCESS TO
PERSONALIZED AND INTENSIVE
SUPPORT, ULTIMATELY INCREASING
THEIR CHANCES OF SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETING HIGH SCHOOL AND
TRANSITIONING TO POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. SECONDLY, THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT FOSTER YOUTH
ARE NOT INADVERTENTLY OPTED OUT
OF COMPLETING A FAFSA, CAUSING
THEM TO MISS OUT ON THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS WORTH OF FINANCIAL AID.
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAMS ARE TASKED
WITH ENSURING THAT THE
EDUCATIONAL NEEDS OF FOSTER
YOUTH ARE MET, INCLUDING THAT
THEY'RE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPLY FOR FINANCIAL AID.
FULFILLING THIS RESPONSIBILITY
IS HAMPERED WHEN STUDENTS ARE
OPTED OUT OF COMPLETING THE
FAFSA WITHOUT THE PROGRAM'S
KNOWLEDGE. THIS PROVISION BUILDS
ON EXISTING COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THESE PROGRAMS AND THEIR
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS. LASTLY,
AB 2137 WILL CREATE AN
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISM THROUGH
THE LCAP TO ENSURE THAT
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES ARE
IDENTIFYING THEIR HOMELESS
STUDENTS AND DEVELOPING
STRATEGIES TO SERVE THESE
STUDENTS THAT LEVERAGE THE
EXPERTISE OF THEIR LOCAL
HOMELESS LIAISONS. THESE THREE
FIXES TO CURRENT LAW ARE SMALL
CHANGES WITH AN OUTSIZED IMPACT
ON THE LIVES OF OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS. FOR THIS
REASON, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB 2137. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME, MISS
HOPE. GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS
WEDNESDAY POPE AND I AM A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. I RECENTLY
GRADUATED FROM FOLSOM LAKE
COLLEGE WITH FOUR ASSOCIATE'S
DEGREES AND WILL BE TRANSFERRING
TO A FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY K¾T.
MY HOPE IS TO SOMEDAY WORK WITH
FOSTER YOUTH IN A DIRECT SERVICE
ROLE. I AM HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
2137, A CRITICAL BILL THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT STUDENTS IN FOSTER
CARE AND THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS HAVE THE SUPPORT
AND RESOURCES THEY NEED TO
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL AND
PURSUE POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
I ENTERED FOSTER CARE AS A
NEWBORN AND SPENT OVER EIGHT
YEARS IN AND OUT OF THE FOSTER
SYSTEM, GROWING UP, I
EXPERIENCED NOT ONLY FOSTER
CARE, BUT EXTREME POVERTY AND NO
ONE EVER SPOKE TO ME ABOUT
COLLEGE AND ITS BENEFITS. EVERY
MEMBER OF MY FAMILY AND ALL OF
THE FOSTER PARENTS I LIVED WITH
NEVER WENT TO COLLEGE AND DIDN'T
KNOW HOW TO GUIDE ME. I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT FINANCIAL AID OR THE
FAFSA EXISTED UNTIL I WALKED
INTO FOLSOM LAKE COLLEGE FOR
FRESHMAN ORIENTATION WHILE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS IN
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE, FINANCIAL
AID BECAME MY LIFELINE. IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THESE YOUTH ARE
INFORMED ABOUT FINANCIAL AID AND
THE FAFSA. BEING EQUIPPED WITH
THIS KNOWLEDGE WOULD HELP FOSTER
AND HOMELESS YOUTH SEE THE
BENEFITS OF COLLEGE AND ENABLE
PROPER PLANNING FOR THEIR LIFE
AND COLLEGE CAREERS. THEIR
STUDENTS IN FOSTER CARE, OR WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
TODAY. JUST LIKE I WAS WHO
STRUGGLE IN SCHOOL AND MAY
BELIEVE THAT COLLEGE IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN'T
AFFORD, THESE YOUNG PEOPLE NEED
SUPPORT FROM PROGRAMS THAT
UNDERSTAND THEIR UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES, WHICH INCLUDES
SUPPORT WITH FAFSA COMPLETION,
AB 2137 WILL ENSURE THAT THE
SPECIALIZED SUPPORT IS AVAILABLE
FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO LACK
GUIDANCE AND A SAFETY NET. THE
SOONER THESE AT RISK AND
UNDERSERVED YOUTH DEMYSTIFY THE
IDEA OF COLLEGE, THE HIGHER THE
LIKELIHOOD THEY WILL ENROLL
EVERY FOSTER AND HOMELESS YOUTH
WHO ENROLLS IN COLLEGE GETS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO END THE CYCLE OF
GENERATIONAL POVERTY IN THEIR
FAMILY, WHICH IS WHY I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE FOR AB 2137. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ARE THERE ANY OTHERS HERE
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE MEASURE? IF SO,
PLEASE COME FORWARD. STATE YOUR
NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION, YOUR
POSITION. HI EVERYONE, I'M ANNIE
THOMAS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. SAM NASH, ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS AND STAFF, MITCH STEIGER
WITH CFT, A UNION OF EDUCATORS
AND CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS,
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
FIRSTLY, KUDOS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MATCHES WITH
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS.
ADAM KAGAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
TELEVISION ACADEMY FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MR.
KAGAN. ARE THERE ANY FOLKS HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE?
SEEING NONE, WE DO NOW HAVE A
QUORUM. LET'S ESTABLISH THAT
QUORUM. MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. NO, JUST. I DON'T
SEE ANY OPPOSITION. DO YOU SEE
ANY OPPOSITION? I CALLED IT,
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM. OKAY.
NEWMAN HERE. NEWMAN HERE. JONES.
I'M HERE. JONES. HERE. CORTEZ
HERE. CORTEZ. HERE. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. HERE. WILK
ALL RIGHT, SO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. LET'S COME BACK TO THE
DAIS. COLLEAGUES, QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR, THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE
IT WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT.
APPRECIATE THAT. ANYBODY ELSE
GLAD TO SUPPORT IT AS WELL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, JUST
APPRECIATE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU, WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SEN
CUEVAS, MADAM, CONSULTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CALL. ITEM
12 AB 2137 QUIRK-SILVA. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATION COMMITTEE. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I JONES. I JONES I
CORTEZ. CORTEZ I, GLAZER.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK OKAY
THAT CURRENTLY HAS FOUR VOTES.
IT WILL GET OUT. WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO THE WITNESSES.
WE'RE ON A ROLL. ANYBODY ELSE?
ANY AUTHORS HERE? NO THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. SEE YOU LATER.
I'M GOING TO DO SOME. DID YOU
WANT TO DO CONSENT? NO. WE. I'D
LIKE TO GET MORE. IT DOES NOT.
IT DOESN'T.
ALL RIGHT. I HAVE MEMBERS THAT
THINK IT WILL BE PROGRESS TO DO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SO LET'S
DO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR? AYE. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR JONES, PLEASE,
MADAM CONSULTANT, CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. NEWMAN.
NEWMAN. AYE. JONES. JONES AYE.
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I WILK. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENTLY HAS
FOUR VOTES. I HOPE EVERYBODY,
EVERYBODY FEELS LIKE THAT WAS
PROGRESS. WE'RE STILL WAITING
FOR ANOTHER AUTHOR.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO MIGHT HAVE
JUST ARRIVED, WE ARE WAITING FOR
AUTHORS TO COME AND PRESENT
THEIR BILL. SO IF YOU HAVE A
BILL BEFORE THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON EDUCATION, AND YOU LIKE THAT
BILL TO BE HEARD, BECAUSE PLEASE
MAKE YOUR WAY TO A COMMITTEE
HEARING ROOM 2100, WE ARE
HONESTLY CONSIDERING ADJOURNING
THIS MEETING AND MOVING THIS
BILLS TO THE FOLLOWING WEEK.
WE'RE ALL EXCITED. WE THOUGHT
FOR A SECOND YOU WERE
ASSEMBLYMAN BRIAN. BUT IT'S NICE
TO SEE YOU KNOW, I'D WELCOME IT
AT THIS POINT.
ALL RIGHT. WE ARE GLAD TO SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES.
WELCOME AND GOOD MORNING, YES.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES. IS IT CORRECT? AB 2033
KIND OF YOU TO DO IT. YOU MAY.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN READY. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 2033, THE
EBT ACCESS FOR STUDENT EMPOWERED
ACT, ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES CALFRESH. BENEFITS
ARE CRITICAL IN HELPING ADDRESS
STUDENT HUNGER, AND IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR STUDENTS TO USE
THESE BENEFITS ON CAMPUSES. AB
2033 DOES TWO THINGS. FIRST, IT
ENSURES THAT COLLEGE STUDENTS
CAN USE THEIR FOOD BENEFITS BY
REQUIRING AT LEAST ONE STORE ON
EACH COLLEGE CAMPUS TO APPLY TO
BECOME AN AUTHORIZED ELECTRONIC
BENEFIT TRANSFER EBT VENDOR. IF
APPROVED, THESE STORES WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ACCEPT EBT.
SECONDLY, THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE
THAT STUDENTS HAVE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE INFORMATION ON EBT
VENDORS ON AND OFF CAMPUSES BY
REQUIRING COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
CSUS, AND REQUESTS THE UCS TO
PROVIDE THE USDA, SNAP
RELAUNCHER LOCATOR LINK, WHICH
PROVIDES UP TO 25 MILE RADIUS
MAP ON EBT VENDORS. A CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION REPORT
NOTES THAT ONLY 127,000 STUDENTS
RECEIVE CALFRESH BENEFITS, AND
THAT ONE THIRD OF ALL
POST-SECONDARY STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED FOOD
INSECURITY. WHILE MANY CSU AND
UC CAMPUSES HAVE BASIC NEEDS,
CENTERS AND BASIC NEED
COORDINATORS, THE BILL REQUIRES
THE CSU AND REQUESTS THE UC TO
ESTABLISH THE CENTERS AND
COORDINATORS, WHOSE DATA
DEMONSTRATES THAT STUDENTS WHO
EXPERIENCE FOOD AND HOUSING
CHALLENGES HAVE LOWER GRADE
POINT AVERAGES AND GRADUATION
RATES COMPARED TO STUDENTS WHO
HAVE THEIR BASIC NEEDS MET. AB
2033 WILL MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR
STUDENTS TO FOCUS ON THEIR
EDUCATION WHILE HAVING THEIR
BASIC NEEDS MET HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL, WE HAVE
VALERIE VALERA AS WELL, A
STUDENT PROGRAM ASSISTANT AT THE
SAN JOAQUIN DELTA COLLEGE,
STUDENT FOOD PANTRY, AND VALERIA
GONZALES MENDEZ, A STUDENT AT UC
DAVIS AND VICE CHAIR OF THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION. WELCOME TO
BOTH THE WITNESSES. YOU EACH
HAVE THREE MINUTES. PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS VALERIE
VALERA, A STUDENT PROGRAM
ASSISTANT AT SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
COLLEGE STUDENT FOOD PANTRY.
TODAY, I STAND BEFORE YOU TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE PASSING OF AB
2033. THIS BILL ADDRESSES A
PRESSING ISSUE THAT AFFECTS
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. FOOD INSECURITY. AS
WE ALL KNOW, PROGRAMS LIKE
CALFRESH ARE VITAL FOR
SUPPORTING LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. HOWEVER, DESPITE
ELIGIBILITY, MANY POST-SECONDARY
STUDENTS ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS
THESE BENEFITS, RESULTING IN A
WIDESPREAD FOOD INSECURITY
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY. COLLEGES
ACCORDING TO REAL COLLEGE
CALIFORNIA, 47% OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
FOOD INSECURE. AB 2033 SEEKS TO
CHANGE THAT BY MANDATING THAT
EACH PUBLIC INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA
HAS AT LEAST ONE EBT. ACCEPTING
VENDOR ON CAMPUS. THIS BILL AIMS
TO PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH THE
MEANS TO UTILIZE THEIR EBT,
WHERE THEY STUDY. ADDITIONALLY,
IT CALLS FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF BASIC NEEDS CENTERS AND
COORDINATORS WITHIN OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS, ENSURING
THAT STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
VITAL RESOURCES AND SUPPORT. BUT
BEHIND EVERY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION, THERE ARE REAL
PEOPLE WITH REAL STORIES. I AM
ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE AS A
STUDENT. FOOD. STUDENT PROGRAM
ASSISTANT AT SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
COLLEGE, STUDENT FOOD PANTRY,
AND A CURRENT STUDENT PURSUING
MY BACHELOR'S DEGREE AT CHICO
UNIVERSITY, I HAVE PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED THE CHALLENGES OF
FOOD INSECURITY. LIKE MANY
OTHERS, I JUGGLE
RESPONSIBILITIES SUCH AS
PARENTING AND COMMUNITY CAMPUS
AND MAKING IT EVEN HARDER TO
FOCUS ON MY EDUCATION. I HAVE
SEEN FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT OF
FOOD INSECURITY ON STUDENTS.
I'VE EXPERIENCED MOMENTS WHERE
BASIC NECESSITIES LIKE FOOD WERE
OUT OF REACH DUE TO LIMITED
OPTIONS AND LACK OF
ACCESSIBILITY. THE AB 2033 IS
ESSENTIAL FOR STUDENTS LIKE ME
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET WHILE TRYING TO BETTER
THEMSELVES THROUGH EDUCATION.
THÀNH PLEASE STAND WITH US.
ADDRESSING THE CRITICAL ISSUE OF
STUDENT FOOD INSECURITY, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME, MISS MENDEZ. HI GOOD
MORNING, MY NAME IS VALERIA
MENDEZ. I'M A STUDENT AT UC
DAVIS, AND I'M THE VICE CHAIR
FOR THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AB 2033. I
PERSONALLY COME FROM AN
IMMIGRANT FAMILY. I WAS RAISED
IN COSTA RICA UNTIL MY SENIOR
YEAR OF HIGH SCHOOL. I HAVE AN
OLDER SISTER WHO WAS OFTEN MY
GUIDE AND MY ROLE MODEL.
HOWEVER, WHEN WE MOVED HERE, WE
BOTH WERE FORCED TO FIGURE OUT
HIGHER EDUCATION AND I FOUND
THAT I COULD NO LONGER LOOK TO
HER FOR, HER HELP AND HER
SUPPORT. SHE ENROLLED AT OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN 2019,
AND I ENROLLED AT UC DAVIS IN
2020. THROUGHOUT OUR JOURNEYS, I
COULD SEE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAD ACCESS
TO. I I MADE NUMEROUS VISITS TO
THE AGGIE CAMPUS BASIC MEAT
CENTER TO RECEIVE HELP
NAVIGATING UC DAVIS. WHILE SHE
WAS LEFT TO FIGURE IT OUT BY
HERSELF, AB 2033 WOULD HELP
INCREASE FOOD AND BASIC NEEDS
ACCESS FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS. I CANNOT TELL YOU
ENOUGH ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
EBT AND FOOD ACCESSIBILITY ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES. FURTHERMORE,
BASIC NEEDS CENTERS HELP BRIDGE
GAPS CREATED BY THE HIGH COST OF
ATTENDING A HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTION OF BEING THE FIRST
IN YOUR FAMILY TO GO TO COLLEGE
OR COMING FROM A LOW INCOME
BACKGROUND. AND CURRENTLY, WHILE
MANY STUDENTS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
CALFRESH BENEFITS, THE LACK OF
EBT ACCEPTANCE ON CAMPUS CAN
IMPOSE ISSUES ON STUDENTS HEALTH
AND ACADEMIC SUCCESS. STUDENTS
MAY ALSO NOT BE AWARE THAT THEY
ARE ELIGIBLE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IT IS VITAL THAT WE GIVE THEM
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED TO
NAVIGATE THESE SYSTEMS, SUCH AS
CENTERS AND QUALIFIED
COORDINATORS. BASIC NEED CENTERS
PROVIDE THE HELP AND GUIDANCE
NEEDED TO UNDERSTANDING CALFRESH
AND ADDRESSING ISSUES THEY FACE
WHILE IN COLLEGE, HIGHLIGHTING
THE IMPORTANCE OF THESE CENTERS
IN REAFFIRMING THEIR BELONGING
ON ALL COLLEGE CAMPUSES. IN
ADDITION, THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE
INCLUDES. THE BILL INCLUDES
PROVISIONS FOR STATE
REIMBURSEMENTS OF ANY MANDATED
COSTS, ENSURING THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE NOT FINANCIALLY BURDENED BY
THIS IMPLEMENTATION. THIS SHOULD
INCENTIVIZE INSTITUTIONS TO
CONTINUE WORKING TOWARDS
ADDRESSING FOOD INSECURITY AND
ACCEPTING EBT ON THEIR CAMPUSES.
AB 2033 IS A CRUCIAL STEP
TOWARDS SUPPORTING THE HEALTH
AND ACADEMIC SUCCESS OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
ALL ALL STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND HELP
CREATE A MORE EQUITABLE AND
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
STUDENTS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE OTHERS HERE
WHO'D LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE MEASURE? SO
PLEASE COME FORWARD. STATE YOUR
NAME, YOUR ORGANIZATION, YOUR
POSITION. ANNA MATTHEWS WITH THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. MITCH STEIGER WITH
CFT, UNION OF EDUCATORS AND
CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS ALSO IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, STEPHANIE
GOLDMAN, ON BEHALF OF THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE, IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING. DANIELLA RODRIGUEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, DO WE HAVE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS MEASURE?
IF SO, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE, WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE DAIS. COMMENTS? QUESTIONS?
MOTION COLLEAGUES, I'VE GOT A
MOTION FROM SENATOR CORTESE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? YES.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I WANT TO
THANK THE STUDENTS WHO ARE HERE
TO TESTIFY AND THOSE WHO LOW
STUDENTS ACROSS OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM, CSU SYSTEMS, ARE
ALL OF OUR COLLEGE CAMPUSES WHO
WE ARE SUPPORTING AND REALLY
SUPPORTING THEIR OVERALL
WELL-BEING. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I SUPPORT. THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT, MADAM
CONSULTANT, WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
SENATOR CORTEZ. YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHILE ITEM NINE AB
2033 REYES THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. NEWMAN,
NEWMAN, I JONES. JONES I CORTEZ.
CORTEZ I. GLASER. GONZALEZ
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK. THAT
MEASURE HAS THREE VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. ESPECIALLY TO
THE WITNESSES. OUR NEXT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, BRIAN, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
AND WELCOME, PLEASE, YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING AB 2046, YOU MAY
PROCEED WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I COME TO
PRESENT AB 2046, WHICH WOULD
EXTEND THE SUNSET DATE FOR THE
AUTHORIZATION OF SINGLE GENDER
SCHOOLS AND CLASSES IN LA USD.
I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY TEAM. IN 2017, AB 23
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED TO ALLOW LA
USD TO CONTINUE OPERATING THEIR
PILOT PROGRAM TO ADDRESS
SPECIFIC EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND
HAVE A BIANNUAL EVALUATION TO
TRACK THEIR RESULTS. THESE
SCHOOLS WERE ESTABLISHED TO
SUPPORT EDUCATION EQUITY BY
INCREASING THE REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES IN STEM AND
LEADERSHIP ROLES, SPECIFICALLY,
THE GIRLS ACADEMY. THE GIRLS
ACADEMIC LEADERSHIP ACADEMY,
WHICH IS LOCATED IN MY DISTRICT,
HAS BEEN SEEKING TO DO JUST
THAT. THE EVALUATIONS DURING THE
PILOT PERIOD WERE IMPACTED
SIGNIFICANTLY BY THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC. EXTENDING THE SUNSET
DATES ALLOWS FOR A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE AND UNINTERRUPTED
EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAMS LONG
TERM IMPACTS. AB 2046 WILL
REMAIN OR WILL MAINTAIN ALL
ORIGINAL PROVISIONS, INCLUDING
BI ANNUAL EVALUATIONS, TO ENSURE
ONGOING ACCOUNTABILITY. THE
AMENDMENTS WILL MAKE EVALUATION
FINDINGS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WEBSITE TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY TO GIVE
TESTIMONY. I'M JOINED BY ANNA
OANA ARCHIMEDES WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THIS BILL SAILED THROUGH CONSENT
, ACROSS ALL ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES
AND ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE, MISS ARCHIMEDES. WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING. ANA ARCHIMEDES, ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT, LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED IS PROUD TO
SPONSOR ASSEMBLY BILL 2046,
WHICH WILL EXTEND THE SUNSET
DATE OF A PILOT PROGRAM
AUTHORIZING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITH DAILY ATTENDANCE OVER
250,000 STUDENTS TO OFFER SINGLE
GENDER EDUCATIONAL OPTIONS. LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED WAS FIRST
AUTHORIZED TO OFFER THIS OPTION
IN 2017, WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB
23. WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED THREE OF
THESE EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS. EACH FOCUSED ON
STEM EDUCATION AND LEADERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED IS ALSO THE AUTHORIZER
FOR THE GIRLS ACADEMIC
LEADERSHIP SCHOOL, A CHARTER,
EXCUSE ME, ATHLETIC ATHLETIC
LEADERSHIP SCHOOL, A CHARTER
SCHOOL FOCUSED ON HEALTH AND
WELLNESS FOR MIDDLE SCHOOL
GIRLS. PURSUANT TO AB 23, LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED HAS CONTRACTED
WITH AN INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY
RESEARCH FIRM TO CONDUCT
EVALUATIONS EVERY TWO YEARS OF
ITS PILOT PROGRAMS. THE RESULTS
ARE PROMISING. STUDENTS
FREQUENTLY OUTPERFORM THEIR
PEERS AT MATCHED COEDUCATION
SCHOOLS AND REPORT HIGHER LEVELS
OF FEELINGS OF BELONGING AND
ACCEPTANCE AT THEIR SCHOOL THAN
THE DISTRICT AVERAGE OR AVERAGE
OF PEER SCHOOLS. THE ANALYSIS
REVEALED THAT THESE SCHOOLS AND
CLASSES ARE ACCEPTING AND
SUPPORTIVE OF LGBTQ STUDENTS.
WHILE THESE EARLY RESEARCH
REPORTS ARE PROMISING, THE THREE
EVALUATIONS CONDUCTED THUS FAR
WERE SUBSTANTIALLY IMPACTED BY
THE DISRUPTIONS OF THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC. FOR THIS REASON, WE
BELIEVE IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
EXTEND THE AUTHORIZATION FOR THE
PILOT PROGRAM TO ALLOW FOR
LONGITUDINAL ASSESSMENT THAT IS
NOT IMPACTED BY A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. LOS ANGELES UNIFIED IS
COMMITTED TO ENSURING ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS RECEIVE AN OPTION TO
CHOOSE THEIR BEST EDUCATIONAL
SETTING SO THEY CAN THRIVE IN
COLLEGE, CAREER AND LIFE. AND
THESE SCHOOLS ARE PROVIDING THAT
OPTION FOR STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
WHO CHOOSE TO ENROLL STUDENTS
THERE. FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, ANY
OTHERS WHO ARE HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE,
PLEASE? MR. CHAIR MEMBERS AMY
BROWN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, ANYBODY ELSE? IS THERE
ANYBODY HERE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DESK, QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS ASKING
FOR AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL THAT
WOULD, ELIMINATE SOME OF THE
PROTECTIONS IN THE SINGLE GENDER
SCHOOLS, MEANING THAT, KIDS THAT
IDENTIFY AS THE OTHER GENDER,
OPPOSITE GENDER OF THEIR BIRTH
COULD BE ENROLLED IN THE SINGLE
GENDER SCHOOL OF WHICH THEY
IDENTIFY WITH. IS THAT ACCURATE?
I BELIEVE THAT'S GENERALLY
ACCURATE. BUT LET ME DEFER TO
THE AUTHOR HERE. GO AHEAD. YEAH,
WITH THE COMMITTEE, AS MUCH AS I
WOULD HAVE LOVED NÓ COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND TO SAIL THROUGH
ON CONSENT IN THIS HOUSE AS WELL
, I THINK WHAT THESE AMENDMENTS
ACTUALLY JUST DO IS CODIFY
WHAT'S ALREADY HAPPENING IN
PRACTICE, THE GIRLS ATHLETIC,
LEADERSHIP SCHOOL, FOR EXAMPLE,
CURRENTLY PROMOTES SERVING GIRLS
PLUS, WHICH IT DESCRIBES AS
STUDENTS WHO ARE GENDER FLUID,
TRANSGENDERED STUDENTS WHO
IDENTIFY AS GIRLS, NON-BINARY
STUDENTS, AND EVERYTHING IN
BETWEEN. I THINK THE GOAL HERE
IS TO CLOSE THE EXCELLENCE GAPS
THAT WE ARE NOTICING BETWEEN
GENDERS, BUT ALSO FOR STUDENTS
WHO ARE NON-BINARY OR GENDER
FLUID. THE SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY
DOING THIS. I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS JUST CLARIFY AND
CODIFY THAT. THAT'S ALLOWED.
OKAY. I APPRECIATE THAT ANSWER.
AND IT'S AND THAT'S KIND OF WHAT
I EXPECTED AS WELL. YOU KNOW, I
THINK THE SINGLE GENDER SCHOOLS
ARE A GREAT IDEA. I WOULD YOU
KNOW, I SUPPORT THIS, CONCEPT
TOTALLY, WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS,
THOUGH, IT CAUSES ME SOME
CONCERN, I HAVE A DAUGHTER. I
HAVE TWO BOYS, IF MY DAUGHTER
WANTED TO GO TO A SINGLE GENDER
SCHOOL AND PLAY VOLLEYBALL,
WHICH SHE DID PLAY VOLLEYBALL IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND IN COLLEGE, I
WOULD HAVE A REALLY DIFFICULT
TIME OF HER PLAYING AGAINST A
SIX FOOT SEVEN, 200 POUND MALE.
SURE, AND SO FOR THAT CONCERN,
I'LL BE VOTING NO TODAY. SORRY
ABOUT THAT. NO WORRIES. WHAT IF
IT WAS A FIVE FOOT FOUR? I
FORGET IT. SO SHE IS FIVE FOOT
FOUR. WHAT IF SHE'S TOUGHER THAN
MOST? SIX FOOT SEVEN BOYS? VÌ.
OKAY, INTERESTING THAT YOU
FOCUSED ON THE SIX FOOT SEVEN
PIECE, MOST MALE VOLLEYBALL
PLAYERS ARE. APPRECIATE THAT, NO
WONDER I WASN'T VERY GOOD. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE FROM THE DAIS? REASONS WHY
YOU WEREN'T GOOD? NO, NO, NO. IF
I WERE FIVE INCHES TALLER, I
WOULDN'T BE HERE. I AND I THINK
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS. SO IS
THERE A TWEENER HERE DEREK
LENNOX. OH I'M SORRY. DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT BILL. THANK
YOU. CONSULTANT. SORRY. DO I
HAVE A MOTION. AND WE DO. OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
APPRECIATE THAT. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR SENATOR CORTEZ. MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR ITEM TEN AB 2046. BRIAN, THE
MOTION IS Dð PASSES AMENDED TO
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN NEWMAN I. JONES. NO.
JONES. NO. CORTEZ. CORTEZ I.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD
CUEVAS. WILK ALL RIGHT. WELL,
THAT MEASURE CURRENTLY HAS TWO
VOTES FOR ONE AGAINST. WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRIAN. THANK YOU, AND THANK YOU
TO YOUR WITNESS. APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE. ALL RIGHT, NEXT UP,
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON.
WELCOME. GLAD TO HAVE YOU HERE,
AGAIN, A LITTLE EARLY. NO,
YOU'RE NOT YOU'RE NOT, YOU'RE
NOT SNEAKING IN. WE'RE GLAD TO
SEE YOU, YOU'LL BE PRESENTING AB
3223, AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. THANK YOU. WELL GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 3223, WHICH WOULD
CLARIFY THE APPLICABILITY OF THE
FOSTER YOUTH SERVICES
COORDINATING PROGRAM AND ALSO
SERVING YOUTH WITH WILK 602
POSITION WHO HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS TITLE FOR Â
CANDIDATE AND A RISK OF
PLACEMENT. CURRENTLY, THE
EDUCATION CODE ESTABLISHES AND
I'M GOING TO ABBREVIATE THE
PREVIOUS WORD BY FICEP, INCLUDES
FOSTER YOUTH IN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM AND ARE IN
PLACEMENT, AS WELL AS YOUTH WHO
REMAIN IN THE HOME AND ARE
RECEIVING FAMILY MAINTENANCE
SERVICES. ALSO INCLUDED AS
ELIGIBLE YOUTH FOR THIS PROGRAM
ARE YOUTH WITH A WEEK 602
PETITION WHO HAVE BEEN MADE
WARDS OF THE COURT AND ORDERED
INTO FOSTER CARE. HOWEVER YOUTH
THAT PROBATION WORKS WITH THAT
ARE SUBJECT TO. AND I'M GOING TO
SAY WIC. JUST TO BE CLEAR. 602
PETITION A RISK OF PLACEMENT AS
IDENTIFIED AS TITLE FOR Â
CANDIDATES, WHICH ARE SIMILAR IN
NATURE TO CHILD WELFARE, YOUTH
AND FAMILY MAINTENANCE ARE NOT
EXPRESSLY INCLUDED. THE SERVICES
PROVIDED VIA THE FIE CCP WOULD
BE BENEFICIAL TO THESE YOUTH IN
THEIR EDUCATIONAL DEVELOPMENT,
BUT ALSO IS NOT EXPRESSLY
REFLECTED IN THE EDUCATIONAL
CODE SECTION 42921 BY EXPRESSLY
CLARIFYING THAT THESE YOUTH ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THESE TYPES OF
SERVICES, IT SUPPORTS PARITY FOR
THIS POPULATION OF YOUTH AND
ALLOWS FOR THEM TO RECEIVE
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORTS, MENTORING,
TUTORING, AND OTHER SERVICES
THROUGH THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WITH THE GOAL OF
SUPPORTING THEIR EDUCATIONAL
NEEDS AND AN EFFORT TO HELP
PROVIDE STABILITY IN THE HOME
AND MITIGATE RISK OF PLACEMENT
WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY IS
DANIELLE SANCHEZ, ON BEHALF OF
CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA. GOOD MORNING, MISS
SANCHEZ. WELCOME. PLEASE PROCEED
. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. DANIELLE SANCHEZ, ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA, PLEASED
TO BE THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
AND, VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WORK WITH US ON
THIS. PROBATION CHIEFS RECOGNIZE
THE VERY IMPORTANT ROLE THAT
EDUCATION PLAYS IN A YOUTH'S
LIFE, PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT
ARE BEING SERVED IN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND FOSTER CARE
SYSTEMS IN PROVIDING STABILITY
AND PATHWAYS FOR THEIR FUTURE,
PROBATION CHIEFS ARE ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR EFFORTS AND
PRACTICES TO KEEP YOUTH FROM
COMING INTO CONTACT IN THE
SYSTEM IN THE FIRST PLACE, BUT
THEN ALSO LOOKING AT HOW DO WE
BUILD THOSE LASTING SUPPORTS AND
PATHWAYS TO HELP DIRECT THEM OUT
OF THE SYSTEM IN A SUSTAINABLE,
IN A SUSTAINABLE WAY? THIS BILL
REALLY IS ABOUT THAT GOAL AND
ABOUT SEEKING TO PROVIDE PARITY
FOR A SPECIFIC POPULATION OF
YOUTH WHO ARE SIMILARLY SITUATED
TO YOUTH IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM, OFTEN, WHICH YOU HAVE
MANY OF THE SAME, CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND WOULD BENEFIT
FROM THESE SERVICES. OUR GOAL IN
DOING THIS IS IN LARGE PART THAT
IF WE CAN KEEP YOUTH AND
FAMILIES STABILIZED IN THEIR
HOME BEFORE HAVING TO ENTER
PLACEMENT, AND WE KNOW EDUCATION
IS A CRITICAL COMPONENT AMONG
MANY IN DOING THAT, THAT IN
TURN, HELPS TO MITIGATE
POTENTIAL FOSTER YOUTH
PLACEMENTS AND HAVING TO BE
REMOVED FROM THE HOME AND ENDING
UP IN A FOSTER CARE PLACEMENT.
AND SO WE SEE THIS BOTH AS
ADVANCING THE YOUTH'S
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORTS, SUPPORTING
THEIR FAMILY AND PREVENTING,
FURTHER PLACEMENT INTO A SYSTEM
AND KEEPING THEM STABILIZED IN
THE HOME, SO THESE SUPPORTS
CERTAINLY WE RECOGNIZE THROUGH
THE COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
AS, AS PARTNERS WITH PROBATION
AND PROVIDING MANY SERVICES TO
THESE TYPES OF YOUTH, THAT THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT, EFFORT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GIVING
MENTORING, TUTORING AND RELATED
SERVICES, AGAIN TO A SIMILARLY
SITUATED, SET OF YOUTH FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. SO FOR THOSE
REASONS, WE'RE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE AND ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ARE THERE ANY OTHERS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE? IF SO,
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SEEING NONE
, IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OR
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE? SEEING NONE, LET'S COME
BACK TO THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES, WE
HAVE A TWEENER. HERE'S THE
TWEENER, PLEASE. WELCOME, MISTER
LENNOX. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M DEREK LENNOX WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS. I REPRESENT THE
58 COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS OF
SCHOOLS THAT OPERATE THESE
FOSTER YOUTH SERVICES
COORDINATING PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
DISTRICTS AND STUDENTS IN FOSTER
Dð THREE IS ONE OF CONCERN, BUT
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE MANY
COLLABORATIVE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE AND WITH THE SPONSORS AND
I ALSO WANT TO START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WILSON FOR HER SPECIAL FOCUS ON
THIS STUDENT POPULATION. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN ON
PROBATION WHO ARE IN THE HOME
BUT AT IMMINENT RISK OF REMOVAL.
WE KNOW FROM THE RESEARCH THAT
ADJUDICATED YOUTH OFTEN HAVE AS
MUCH EXPOSURE TO TRAUMA AND
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES AS
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE, SO
WE'RE VERY SENSITIVE TO THAT.
BUT WITH THAT ACKNOWLEDGMENT, WE
RESPECTFULLY HAVE TWO CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL. THE FIRST IS TO
ENSURE THAT THE CURRENT SERVICES
THAT THESE COORDINATING PROGRAMS
OFFER TO FOSTER YOUTH ARE NOT
REDUCED OR HARMED IN ANY WAY BY
THE ADDITION OF NEW STUDENTS
BEING SERVED WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. THE FIXED POT OF MONEY
RIGHT NOW THAT GOES TO THEM. AND
SECOND IS THERE IS CURRENTLY NO
SYSTEM THAT OFFERS A REGULAR
DATA MATCH BETWEEN COUNTY
PROBATION AND SCHOOL AGENCIES,
SUCH THAT SCHOOLS COULD IDENTIFY
THE STUDENTS UNDER THE BILL. WE
HOPE THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS
WILL EXIST IN THE FUTURE, AND WE
WOULD THEN BE ABLE TO
OPERATIONALIZE THIS BILL. BUT
UNTIL THEN, WE REGRET THAT THIS
PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE AN
IMPLEMENTABLE BILL FOR US ON THE
FOSTER YOUTH SERVICES
COORDINATING SIDE, BUT I WILL
END WHERE I STARTED. WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT A STUDENT
POPULATION WITH SIGNIFICANT
NEEDS, AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
THIS BILL IS PROMOTING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THOSE NEEDS.
WE'RE NOT DOING ENOUGH AS AN
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM FOR ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS, INCLUDING THIS
SPECIAL POPULATION. SO ON BEHALF
OF THE 58 COUNTY SUPERINTENDENTS
OF SCHOOLS, I LOOK FORWARD TO
MANY MORE CONVERSATIONS TO COME.
AND THANK YOU. THANK YOU, ONCE
AGAIN, ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE, COME BACK TO THE
DAIS. GOOD. A MOTION, SENATOR
LET ME TO, MISTER LENNOX'S POINT
ABOUT IMPLEMENTABILITY. I ASSUME
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU'LL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
SUPERINTENDENTS ON THIS?
ABSOLUTELY, ABSOLUTELY. I THINK
THAT THE ORIGINAL STUDENTS
WITHIN THIS POPULATION ARE THE
PRIORITY, AND THEN THIS IS
INCLUSION, RECOGNIZING THAT IF
WE CAN BE PROACTIVE IN THIS
AREA, THEN WE CAN RISK FURTHER
TRAUMA TO THESE ADDITIONAL
STUDENTS. AND SO WE'LL FIGURE
OUT HOW TO, HAVE THAT IN
LANGUAGE, AND AS WELL AS
RECOGNIZING THAT, YOU KNOW,
ESPECIALLY IN A YEAR LIKE THIS
YEAR, THAT FUNDING IS AN ISSUE.
AND WHEN YOU'RE ADDING,
EXPANDING THE UNIVERSE THAT
COULD BE PROBLEMATIC TO EXISTING
STUDENTS. AND THAT'S WHY I THINK
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY,
PARTICULARLY TO PRIORITIZE THE
EXISTING STUDENTS. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. BUT, YOU KNOW,
TO THAT QUESTION ABOUT SHARING
DATA AND MAKING SURE YOU'RE
MATCHING, IF YOU COULD SPEAK TO
THAT, BECAUSE THAT SEEMS TO ME
TO BE THE MORE IMPORTANT OF THE
TWO CONCERNS. RIGHT, AND
FIGURING OUT HOW TO DO THAT. AND
SO WE ARE HAVING THOSE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS. AND SO I'M
ABSOLUTELY OPEN AND WILLING TO
THAT IF WE CAN GET THAT LANGUAGE
IN THERE, FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE
BEST WAY TO GET THAT LANGUAGE IN
THERE TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S A
SHARING CAPABILITIES, WE WILL DO
THAT. THAT'S NOT AN ISSUE LIKE
BOTH BOTH OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP, AS THE TWEENER,
AND THE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS, WE WANT TO
ADDRESS THOSE. AND SO IT'S JUST
A MATTER OF HOW AND SOMETIMES IT
TAKES A MINUTE TO FIGURE OUT THE
HOW, SOMETIMES MORE THAN A
MINUTE. OKAY. WE ONLY HAVE A
MINUTE LEFT, SO WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT IN A MINUTE. SO I'M GLAD
TO SUPPORT IT. I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US, THE
SUPERINTENDENTS, TO DO THAT, WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR SENATOR
CORTEZ. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
JUST TO SAY THAT I APPRECIATE,
NOT ONLY THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL. THIS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT, ISSUE. AND IT REALLY
IS A PROACTIVE MEASURE TO ENSURE
THAT WE REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
TRAUMA, AND, AND, AND RECOGNIZE
THAT STUDENTS WHO ARE YOUTH WHO
ARE IN IMMEDIATE RISK OF
PLACEMENT NEED THESE TYPES OF
SERVICES, AS WELL AS RECOGNIZING
OUR SUPERINTENDENT. THAT'S PLAY
A VITAL ROLE IN OVERSIGHT TO
THESE TYPE OF STUDENTS. AND WE
WANT TO GIVE THEM THE RESOURCES
THAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THIS EFFECTIVELY. AND
I'M ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO
DOING THAT. I DO NOT WANT A BILL
THAT IS A GOOD BILL FOR AT A
MACRO LEVEL, I WANT A BILL THAT
ACTUALLY WILL WORK AND THAT
WE'LL BE ABLE TO SEE PROGRESS
FOR THESE STUDENTS WHO ARE, THE
VULNERABLE PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND WE ALL KNOW AS
LEGISLATORS THAT IS OUR ROLE TO
PROTECT THE VULNERABLE. AND SO
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. I APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTEZ. MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHILE ITEM 24 AB 2032 23 WILSON.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN I JONES, A JONES
I CORTEZ. CORTEZ I GLASER.
GONZALES SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK
WILK I. ALL RIGHT. THAT MEASURE
CURRENTLY HAS FOUR VOTES. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE TIME
BEING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO OUR
WITNESSES, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTHY, IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU,
AND THAT IS A SPIFFY SUMMER
SUIT. AND WELCOME. EVERY DAY,
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING, AB 2076,
AND YOU MAY YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY. YES. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, THIS IS A TOPIC YOU MAY
BE FAMILIAR WITH ABOUT BUILDING,
ADDITIONAL STUDENT HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA. WE CREATED LAST
YEAR, IN THE BUDGET AND TWO
YEARS AGO, THROUGH STATUTE, THE
STUDENT HOUSING REVOLVING LOAN
FUND. UNFORTUNATELY WITH THE
BUDGET SITUATION, WE DON'T HAVE
A LOT OF GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
LAYING AROUND TO INVEST IN
BUILDING NEW STUDENT HOUSING.
AND WE KNOW THE COSTS OF
STUDENTS AND GOING TO COLLEGE IS
TREMENDOUS. IT'S NOT ONLY
TUITION, IT'S FOOD, IT'S
TRANSPORTATION, IT'S BOOKS. BUT
THE BIG COST IS HOUSING. AND SO
COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE TRYING TO
BUILD MORE STUDENT HOUSING TO
MEET THE CURRENT, NEEDS OF
STUDENTS. BUT ALSO AS WE ATTEMPT
TO GROW AND ENROLL MORE
CALIFORNIANS IN UC AND CSU, SO
DESPERATELY TRYING TO FIND TOOLS
TO HELP UC AND CSU FUND
ADDITIONAL STUDENT HOUSING, THIS
IS AN IDEA THAT CAME ABOUT
THROUGH TALKING TO THE SEGMENTS,
LOOKING FOR A CREATIVE WAY TO
PUT MONEY ON THE TABLE, THIS
WOULD AUTHORIZE IT WOULDN'T
ACTUALLY PUT MONEY ON THE TABLE.
IT WOULD AUTHORIZE THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS THE ABILITY TO
BORROW MONEY FROM THE POOLED
MONEY INVESTMENT ACCOUNT INTO
THE STUDENT HOUSING REVOLVING
FUND, TO PROVIDE NEEDED
RESOURCES FOR UC AND CSU TO
BUILD ADDITIONAL STUDENT
HOUSING. WITH ME TODAY IS A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
GUERRA. WELCOME. PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING, MR.
CHAIR. DID I JUST TURN IT ON?
YEAH THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, MY NAME IS MARIO
GUERRERO. I AM THE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR BUSINESS OPERATION
FOR THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY, THE UNIVERSITY
HAS SIGNIFICANT DEMAND FOR ON
CAMPUS STUDENT HOUSING. THIS IS
DEMONSTRATED BY THE OVER 16,000
STUDENTS WHO WERE WAITLISTED FOR
CAMPUS HOUSING IN FALL OF 2023.
THE REVOLVING FUND WOULD BE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN HELPING THE
UNIVERSITY FINANCE ADDITIONAL
BEDS. THE LOAN FUND PROVIDES A
LOWER COST FROM A FORM OF
FINANCING, WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE
UNIVERSITY TO EXTEND ITS
RESOURCES AND ENSURE CAMPUS,
STUDENT HOUSING REMAINS
AFFORDABLE. UNDER THIS PROGRAM,
THE UNIVERSITY WOULD PAY BACK
ANY LOAN IT RECEIVES AND 3%
INTEREST IN THE LOAN. THIS IS A
LOWER INTEREST RATE THAN THE
UNIVERSITY COULD GET WITH ITS
OWN FINANCING. IT WOULD MEAN
THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME PROJECT
SAVINGS THAT COULD BE PASSED ON
TO STUDENTS EVERY YEAR FOR THE
30 YEAR TERM OF THE LOAN. I
SHOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY WOULD BE USING ITS
GENERAL REVENUE BOND FINANCING
ALONG WITH THE REVOLVING LOAN
FUND, TO FINANCE ANY STUDENT
HOUSING PROJECT. HAVING ACCESS
TO THE REVOLVING LOAN FUND WOULD
HELP THE UNIVERSITY FINANCE
ADDITIONAL STUDENT HOUSING BEDS
FASTER THAN WE COULD WITH OTHER
MEANS OF FINANCING. IN ADDITION,
SINCE THE FUND IS REVOLVING, THE
FUND THAT IS PAID BACK TO THE
REVOLVING FUND COULD ALSO BE
REDEPLOYED FOR FUTURE STUDENT
HOUSING PROJECTS. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE, PLEASE
COME FORWARD. WELCOME. GOOD
MORNING, ERIC PARKER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR. STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE. SO
PLEASE COME FORWARD. SEEING
NONE, LET'S COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS. SENATOR JONES, QUICK
CONCERN. THERE'S SOME CONCERN
THAT THIS IS A BUDGET ITEM AND
ACTUALLY SHOULD GO THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS, DO YOU WANT TO
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT? YEAH. IN
THE BILL, IT SAYS UPON
APPROPRIATION. SO THAT'S THIS
STATE'S UP STATUTORY AUTHORITY
TO DO SO. THERE HAVE BEEN
SEVERAL IDEAS FLOATED THE LAST
FEW YEARS DURING BUDGET TIMES TO
USE MONEY IN OUR STATE POOLED
ACCOUNT FOR STATE PURPOSES, AND
THIS WOULD AUTHORIZE THIS TO
HAPPEN. AND WE THINK THIS ONE'S
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT, BECAUSE
AS THE èC SAID, THEY WOULD THEY
WOULD PAY INTEREST ON IT AS
WELL. SO THE STATE WOULDN'T
NECESSARILY HAVE MUCH AS MUCH OF
A LOSS. SO IT IS A POLICY AND
BUDGET THING WORKING IN TANDEM.
BUT IT DOES SAY SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION AND ACTION IN THE
BUDGET. OKAY, I'M ON
APPROPRIATIONS AS WELL. SO I'M
GOING TO LAY OFF TODAY AND LOOK
AT IT IN APPROPRIATIONS. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. FROM MY PART, I
YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE YOUR
CREATIVITY AND YOUR COMMITMENT
TO GETTING THIS DONE, I, I'M OF
THE BELIEF THAT THE HOUSING
DEFICIT ACROSS THE CAMPUSES IN
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE, THE
BIGGEST, MOST PRESSING ISSUES WE
HAVE TO SOLVE FOR OUR STUDENTS
HAS A HUGE IMPACT ON THE QUALITY
OF EDUCATION. SO I, I DO COMMEND
YOU ON ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS.
AND TO YOUR POINT, THIS IS
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATIONS. SO
THAT'S A SEPARATE MATTER. BUT AS
A MATTER OF POLICY I'M GLAD TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY, DO WE HAVE A
MOTION SO MOVED FROM SENATOR
WILK. ANY OTHER COMMENTS,
COLLEAGUES? NO. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YEAH, LIKE YOU SAID,
THIS IS SUCH A KEY ISSUE, NOT
JUST FOR CURRENT STUDENTS
AFFORDING COLLEGE, BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET, YOU KNOW, TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF MORE CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE APPLYING TO UC AT RECORD
NUMBERS WITH AMAZING GRADES,
TRYING TO GET THEM SLOTS INTO UC
AND UC AND CSU'S COME BACK AND
THEY SAY THERE'S ONE ISSUE
HOUSING. SO THIS IS KEY TO OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION GOALS IN THE
LONG RUN. AND, YOU KNOW, ONE OF
THE THINGS I'M MOST PROUD ABOUT
WORKING ON, I CREATED THIS
STUDENT, HOUSING FUND, AND WE
HAD $1.8 BILLION IN THE BUDGET
LAST YEAR OVER THREE YEARS, AND
THAT'S JUST NOT THERE ANYMORE.
SO WHAT DO WE DO? DO WE THROW UP
OUR HANDS AND BE LIKE, WE CAN'T
DO IT? NO, WE HAVE TO LOOK FOR
CREATIVE WAYS TO ACHIEVE THE
GOALS THAT WE'RE AFTER. AND SO
THIS IS WHAT THIS WOULD DO. AND
IT'S A TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
WE'RE TALKING TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP ABOUT POTENTIALLY
USING THIS TO BUILD MORE STUDENT
HOUSING AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
WILK. MADAM PRESIDENT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM 13 AB
2076 MCCARTY. THE MOTION IS DUE.
PASS TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. I JONES.
CORTESE. CORTESE I. GLAZER.
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK
WILK I. ALL RIGHT. THAT MEASURE
CURRENTLY HAS TWO VOTES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. THREE VOTES, THREE VOTES.
I'M SORRY, AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS. WELCOME. ARE YOU ARE MORE
THAN WELCOME, AND YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING AB 2377, PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS
, I WANT TO START BY THANKING
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS BILL. AB
2377 SEEKS TO PROVIDE
ACCOMMODATE OPTIONS FOR STUDENTS
PRACTICING RELIGIOUS FASTING BY
OFFERING THEM A MODIFIED
EXERCISE REGIME OR PROVIDING
THEM WITH ACADEMIC ASSIGNMENTS
RELATED TO PHYSICAL EDUCATION.
SPECIFICALLY, THIS BILL REQUIRES
WRITTEN PERMISSION FROM PARENTS
FOR STUDENTS UNDER 18 TO REQUEST
PE ACCOMMODATIONS. AS FASTING IS
THE ACT OF REFRAINING COMPLETELY
OR PARTIALLY FROM CONSUMING
ANYTHING OF SUSTENANCE DURING
RAMADAN, MUSLIMS FAST EVERY DAY
FOR 30 DAYS FROM SUNRISE TO
SUNSET AS A SPIRITUAL
DISCIPLINE, PEOPLE IN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY WHO OBSERVE YOM
KIPPUR, THE HOLIEST DAY OF THE
YEAR IN JUDAISM, PRACTICE A DAY
LONG, FAST AND INTENSIVE PRAYER
THAT REQUIRES FULL ABSTENTION
FROM FOOD AND LIQUIDS.
ADDITIONALLY, SEVERAL CHRISTIAN
DENOMINATIONS PRACTICE FULL OR
PARTIAL FASTING ON CERTAIN
OCCASIONS, INCLUDING LENT. OTHER
STATES HAVE RECOGNIZED THE NEED
TO PROVIDE PROPER ACCOMMODATIONS
FOR STUDENTS OBSERVING RELIGIOUS
FASTING, WITH ILLINOIS PASSING
HOUSE BILL 160, WHICH PERMITS
STUDENTS TO AVOID RIGOROUS
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY DURING PERIODS
OF RELIGIOUS FASTING. CURRENTLY,
STUDENTS FROM GRADES ONE THROUGH
EIGHTH ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLETE
200 MINUTES EVERY TEN SCHOOL
DAYS, AND STUDENTS FROM NINTH
THROUGH 12TH ARE REQUIRED. 400
MINUTES EVERY TEN SCHOOL DAYS TO
FULFILL THEIR PE REQUIREMENTS.
THERE ARE NO GUIDELINES WITHIN
THE SCHOOL SYSTEM THAT PROVIDE
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR STUDENTS WHO
ARE FASTING DURING THE PE
PORTION OF THE DAY. THE
IMPLICATIONS OF FASTING IN THE
SUMMER DAYS ARE EVEN MORE
DANGEROUS, AS FACTORS LIKE
SWELTERING HEAT CAN CREATE
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS FOR
STUDENTS, SUCH AS HEADACHES,
DEHYDRATION, WHICH MAY LEAD TO
FAINTING DURING EXERCISE. TODAY
I HAVE WITH ME TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY, ROSA HEYDARI,
PRESIDENT OF THE AFGHAN STUDENT
ASSOCIATION FROM LAGUNA CREEK
HIGH SCHOOL, AND FAUZIA FAROOQ,
POLICY AND ADVOCACY COORDINATOR
FROM THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS, WHOSE FIRST,
MISS HEYDARI, WELCOME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, CHAIR, VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
ROSA HEYDARI. I'M A STUDENT AND
THE PRESIDENT OF THE AFGHAN
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE MUSLIM STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AT LAGUNA CREEK HIGH
SCHOOL. AS A STUDENT THAT HAS
PARTICIPATED IN PHYSICAL
EDUCATION FOR MORE THAN THREE
YEARS WHILE IN THE STATE OF
RELIGIOUS FASTING, I RECALL
EXPERIENCING EXTREME PHYSICAL
EXHAUSTION AFTER THE ACTIVITIES,
I CAN STRONGLY AFFIRM THAT
PHYSICAL EXHAUSTION IMPACTS A
STUDENT'S ABILITY TO FOCUS AND
PERFORM WELL IN OTHER ACADEMIC
AREAS, HAVING REDUCED ENERGY
LEVELS RESULTED IN FATIGUE,
WHICH MADE IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
CONCENTRATE AND BE ENGAGED IN.
MY OTHER IMPORTANT ACADEMIC
COURSES. EXCUSING STUDENTS THAT
ARE IN THE STATE OF RELIGIOUS
FASTING WILL ALLOW THEM TO
CONSERVE THEIR ENERGY FOR THEIR
ACADEMIC WORK, SUPPORTING BETTER
OVERALL EDUCATIONAL PERFORMANCE.
PARTICIPATING IN PE WHILE
FASTING BROUGHT UPON A UPON A
LOT OF NOT ONLY PHYSICAL
DISCOMFORT, BUT AS WELL AS
MENTAL, IT NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
MY ABILITY TO GRASP NEW
CONCEPTS, PARTICIPATE IN
DISCUSSIONS, AND COMPLETE WORK
IN MY OTHER CLASSES EFFECTIVELY,
WHICH OVERALL LIMITED MY
LEARNING. THUS, AB 2377 IS VERY
IMPORTANT AS IT WILL ALLOW
STUDENTS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
MENTAL WELL-BEING, WHICH LEADS
TO A MORE POSITIVE SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE. FURTHERMORE EXCUSING
FASTING STUDENTS FROM PHYSICAL
EDUCATION ALIGNS WITH THE
EDUCATIONAL PRINCIPLES OF SAFETY
WHILE ALSO PROMOTING A
SUPPORTIVE, ACCOMMODATED
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT. I REQUEST
THE COMMITTEE JUST VOTE AND
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, MISS FAROOQ. WELCOME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. CHAIR,
VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS FOZIA FAROOQ
AND I'M THE POLICY AND ADVOCACY
COORDINATOR AT THE COUNCIL ON
AMERICAN-ISLAMIC RELATIONS. WE
PROUDLY SPONSOR AB 2377, A BILL
THAT RESONATES DEEPLY WITH MY
OWN SCHOOL EXPERIENCES AND THOSE
OF MANY STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. REFLECTING BACK ON
MY SCHOOL JOURNEY, I FACED
REPEATED CHALLENGES DURING
RAMADAN WHEN FASTING MADE
PARTICIPATING IN PHYSICAL
EDUCATION BOTH DIFFICULT AND
UNSAFE. LIKE MANY OTHERS, I HAD
TO NAVIGATE THE CONFLICT BETWEEN
ADHERING TO MY RELIGIOUS
PRACTICES AND FULFILLING SCHOOL
PE REQUIREMENTS, OFTEN RISKING
MY HEALTH AND ACADEMIC STANDING.
CURRENTLY, WHILE STUDENTS WITH
MEDICAL NEEDS CAN RECEIVE
EXEMPTIONS, THOSE OBSERVING
RELIGIOUS FASTS LACK SIMILAR
ACCOMMODATIONS, AND THIS GAP
IMPACTS NOT JUST PHYSICAL HEALTH
, BUT ALSO ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
AND EMOTIONAL WELL-BEING,
FOSTERING A SENSE OF EXCLUSION.
AB 2377 SEEKS TO BRIDGE THIS GAP
BY ALLOWING ALLOWING STUDENTS TO
BE EXCUSED FROM PHYSICAL
ACTIVITIES DURING RELIGIOUS
FASTING, ENSURING THEY ARE NOT
PENALIZED ACADEMICALLY. THIS
BILL REPRESENTS A STEP TOWARDS A
MORE INCLUSIVE, RESPECTFUL
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT, DRAWING
ON SUCCESSFUL PRECEDENTS LIKE
ILLINOIS HOUSE BILL 160, WHICH
SIMILARLY PROVIDES
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR STUDENTS
OBSERVING RELIGIOUS FASTS. AB
2377 ALIGNS WITH ESTABLISHED
PRACTICES SUPPORTING STUDENT
HEALTH AND INCLUSION. THIS
COMPARISON UNDERSCORES THE
IMPORTANCE AND FEASIBILITY OF
SUCH MEASURES. I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB 2377 AFFIRMING OUR
OUR COMMITMENT TO AN EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM THAT HONORS DIVERSITY AND
SUPPORTS EVERY STUDENT'S RIGHT
TO PARTICIPATE FULLY AND SAFELY,
SAFELY. EXCUSE ME. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ANY OTHERS HERE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE, MR. STEIGER? THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MITCH STEIGER
WITH CFT, A UNION OF EDUCATORS
AND CLASSIFIED PROFESSIONALS,
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE? DOES ANYBODY HERE
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE?
SEEING NONE, COME BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHORS.
SENATOR WILK MOVES THE BILL.
OKAY. GLAD TO SUPPORT THE BILL,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, IN ADDITION TO
OUR SPONSORS, I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK, MY LEGISLATIVE AIDE,
OMAR, THAT PROPOSED THIS BILL
IDEA TO ME BASED ON HIS OWN
EXPERIENCES DURING RAMADAN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. WE
DO HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
WILK, MADAM CONSULTANT, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL WHILE ITEM 19, AB
2377 THREE OF US. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. NEWMAN A NEWMAN. AYE.
JONES A JONES. AYE. CORTESE.
CORTESE I GLASER. GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WILK. WILK I.
THAT MEASURE HAS FOUR VOTES.
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE TIME
BEING, BUT IT WILL PASS. THANK
YOU TO THE WITNESSES FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, AND THAT BRINGS US TO OUR
LAST MEASURE FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIAZ. LOOKING FOR
SENATOR WILK. YOU'LL BE
PRESENTING SENATOR JONES. I
DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT,
NEITHER DO I. I'M GOING TO.
SENATOR WILK WILL PRESENT. IT'S
NEVER STOPPED HIM BEFORE. NEVER
STOPPED. ALL RIGHT, I UNDERSTOOD
IT SOUNDS LIKE A PLAN. ALL
RIGHT. YOU WILL BE PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
AB 960. AND YOU MAY PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. YOU'RE MY
WITNESS. I HAD A WITNESS. THAT'S
GOOD. THAT'S HOW GOOD THIS BILL
IS. AND I WAS EARLY. THANK YOU
FOR BEING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY TOLD YOU I
WAS. I WAS AT I NØ TRAINING
SESSION. THAT'S LIKE HIPAA
INFORMATION. WE WOULD YOU
WOULDN'T TELL HIM THAT. YEAH. WE
COVERED FOR YOU. IT'S ALL VERY
OTHER SENATORS DID NOT SHOW US.
IT'S ALL VERY PROFESSIONAL, I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSCIENTIOUS
NESS. I HATE BEING THE ONLY
RESPONSIBLE ONE IN THE ROOM.
YES. ALL RIGHT, MR. CHAIRMAN.
AND MEMBERS, GOOD MORNING. TODAY
ON TODAY. TODAY, ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMAN MATHIS, I'M
PRESENTING AB 960. I'D LIKE TO
START BECAUSE I KNOW YOU'RE
GOING TO ASK, MR. CHAIRMAN, THAT
THE ASSEMBLYMAN HAS ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND STAFF FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH THEIR OFFICE.
THE BILL IS A RESPONSE TO A
TRAGIC, TRAGIC RISE OF SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS. AND I WILL TELL YOU
FROM MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE,
A SCHOOL SHOOTING CAN HAPPEN
ANYWHERE. BACK ON NOVEMBER 14TH,
2019, I WAS IN. I WAS HIKING
THREE TIMES A WEEK TO LOSE
WEIGHT, WHICH I DID OF COURSE, I
GAINED IT ALL BACK, BUT I CAME
HOME ABOUT 730 IN THE MORNING
AND THE TV SET IS ON, AND I'M
LOOKING AT A SHOT, A SHOT DOWN
AND GO, THAT LOOKS LIKE MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. AND IT WAS MY
NEIGHBORHOOD. BECAUSE DOWN AT
THE BOTTOM OF THE HILL IS THE
HIGH SCHOOL THAT MY CHILDREN HAD
ATTENDED. AND THERE WAS A
SHOOTING THERE, TWO STUDENTS
KILLED, TWO MORE WOUNDED,
ACTUALLY THREE STUDENTS, BECAUSE
THE SHOOTER TOOK HIS OWN LIFE.
SO. AND EVERYBODY THAT YOU TALK
TO IS FAMILIAR WITH THE AREA,
SAY, THIS IS LIKE THE LAST
SCHOOL THAT THEY WOULD EVER
THINK THAT WOULD OCCUR, BUT IN
FACT, DID OCCUR. SO AB 960 WITH
FURTHER, THIS EFFORT, BY
ENCOURAGING THE PUBLIC IN TERMS
OF MAKING SCHOOLS SAFER, BY
ENCOURAGING THE PUBLIC AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS, WITH AN
ENROLLMENT OF 100 PUPILS OR MORE
TO IMPLEMENT A WEB BASED OR APP
BASED SCHOOL SAFETY PROGRAM BY
JULY 1ST, 2030. THIS BILL WAS
INSPIRED BY AN APP CALLED AQUA
NET, DEVELOPED BY THE TULARE
OFFICE OF EDUCATION, WHICH MAPS
SCHOOL GROUNDS TO HELP
COORDINATE EMERGENCY RESPONSES
BY LAW ENFORCEMENT. THE APP
PROVED INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE
DURING LIVE ON SITE TRIAL EVENTS
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE
AVERAGE TIME TO APPREHEND OR
ELIMINATE THE SUSPECT WAS 53
SECONDS. WHEN CRISIS. AS SUCH A
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS OCCUR, EVERY
SECOND COUNTS, AND WE OWE IT TO
OUR STUDENTS AND SCHOOL
FACILITIES TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
ENSURE THAT THEY GO HOME TO SAFE
FAMILIES. THIS BILL WILL HELP
MAKE THIS GOAL A REALITY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY IS MY
STAR WITNESS. WELCOME STAR
WITNESS. PLEASE PROCEED. GREG
HERNER, ON BEHALF OF THE ERIC
PERETTA SAVE A LIFE FOUNDATION
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE YOUTH
HEART COALITION, THESE
FOUNDATIONS HAVE BEEN BORN OUT
OF TRAGEDY, OF THE LOSS OF A
CHILD FROM SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST
ON CAMPUSES. WE ARE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF ITS
CO-BENEFITS, SUDDEN CARDIAC
ARREST IS ACTUALLY THE NUMBER
ONE KILLER OF YOUTH ON CAMPUS.
AND I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE THROW
STATISTICS AROUND, BUT IF YOU
ACTUALLY LOOK AT IT, IT IS. AND
WE BELIEVE THAT HAVING THIS TYPE
OF EMERGENCY INFORMATION
AVAILABLE ON AN APP OR OTHER
THING IS GOING TO BE CRITICAL TO
SAVING YOUTH LIVES AND OTHER
PEOPLE THAT ARE FREQUENTING OUR
SCHOOLS. I ACTUALLY HAVE PULLED
UP THE PULSE POINT AED APP HERE,
WHICH HAS PROVIDES THE LOCATION
OF OVER 200 AEDS IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO. THIS IS THE TYPE OF
INFORMATION YOU CAN GLEAN FROM
USING AN APP LIKE THIS. AND
RESPONSE TIME IS CRITICAL TO
SAVING LIVES. CALIFORNIA HAS HAS
ONLY 8% SURVIVAL RATE FOR
STUDENTS ON CAMPUSES. IF YOU HAD
AN AED WITHIN THE FIRST FEW
MINUTES OF SOMEBODY COLLAPSING,
THAT COULD GO UP TO 90, AND WE'D
LIKE TO ALSO JUST MENTION AND
THANK, SENATOR JONES AND SENATOR
BECKER FOR COAUTHORING SR 98,
WHICH WILL BE UP ON THE 17TH,
WHICH WILL RECOGNIZE SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST, OCTOBER SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST MONTH TO BRING
MORE ATTENTION TO THIS, MATTER
OF FACT, SENATOR BECKER JUST
LOST A STUDENT, IN HIS DISTRICT
JUST WEEKS AGO. SO THIS IS A
VERY TIMELY AND IMPORTANT
MEASURE FROM THAT, FROM THAT
STANDPOINT AND FROM ALL THE
CO-BENEFITS STANDPOINTS THAT WE
CAN GET FROM THIS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SO IT DOES APPEAR
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS, BUT WE'RE
TALKING GENERALLY ABOUT RESPONSE
TO ON CAMPUS SAFETY INCIDENTS.
I'M JUST A PRETTY FACE. I OKAY,
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS? NO.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE THE PROS AND
THE CONS FIRST. OH, I'M SO SORRY
, SO MEMBERS OF MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT. I'M SORRY,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION? OH,
WIENER. TWEENERS. GOOD. BECCA
KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION, WE DON'T HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION. JUST
WANTED TO THANK THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE FOR WORKING WITH US ON
OUR CONCERNS. WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
THEY CAN BE ADDRESSED IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE. APPRECIATE THAT.
NEXT, PLEASE. HI. CATALINA
SANCHEZ WITH ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION. AND AGAIN, WE ALSO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR WORK. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. VERY GOOD. THANKS.
YOU, AND VIA HIS PROXY, HE
THANKS YOU, GOING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE, DID I ASK FOR
OPPOSITION? THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION. RIGHT. SO. ALL
RIGHT. DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
THÀNH. I'LL MOVE. SENATOR
CORTEZ, AMENDMENT. OH, YOU HAVE
A QUESTION? OH, PLEASE. OH. I'M
SORRY. SO I'M NOT DOING VERY
WELL HERE. I JUST GO AHEAD ON
THE PLAN WHERE IN TERMS OF THE
MAPPING AND THE EXITS AND ALL OF
THE WHAT'S THE PRIVACY AND
PROTECTION? BECAUSE IF IN THE
WRONG HANDS, THEY COULD ALSO. SO
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE ACLU'S
CONCERNS ARE AS WELL, BECAUSE I
MEAN, WHEN I WAS READING THE
BILL THAT THAT IT CROSSED MY
MIND AND I KNOW HE'S BEEN HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM. THIS IS
COMING TO JUDICIARY NEXT. IF IT
GETS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
. AND I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT HE'S
CONFIDENT THAT ALL THOSE
CONCERNS ARE GOING TO BE
ADDRESSED WITH AMENDMENTS WHEN
IT COMES TO JUDICIARY. OKAY.
YEAH, I MEAN, I ON THE ON THE
FACE OF IT, I UNDERSTAND THE
RIGHT OPPORTUNITY FOR QUICK
RESPONSE. BUT I ALSO KNOW IN THE
WRONG HANDS ABSOLUTELY CREATE
MORE HARM FOR STUDENTS. IF
SOMEONE KNOWS ALL OF THE EXITS,
EMERGENCY PLANS AND SO FORTH, SO
WOULD IT BE ASKING THE GO AHEAD?
YEAH. GO AHEAD. YEAH, AND IT'S
ALSO A CAREFUL BALANCING ACT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT INFORMATION THAT DOES NEED
TO BE PROTECTED IS PROTECTED.
BUT ALSO THAT INFORMATION THAT
HAS A REASON TO BE DISCLOSED
NEEDS TO BE DISCLOSED. AND SO,
FOR EXAMPLE, WANTING TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOLKS WHO ARE CHECKING
THESE EMERGENCY PLANS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE ACCESSIBLE
FOR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES,
FOR EXAMPLE, ALSO HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS INFORMATION. AND SO THAT'S
PART OF WHAT WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON IS WHAT
THAT BALANCE IS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S PUBLIC DISCLOSURE FOR
RECORDS THAT ARE IMPORTANT FOR
THE PUBLIC TO KNOW, AND THAT
THERE'S ALSO PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS. FOR EXAMPLE, WE
ALSO WOULDN'T WANT TO
ACCIDENTALLY DISCLOSE
INFORMATION ABOUT STUDENTS IN
ANY OF THIS. AND SO WORKING ON
THAT BALANCE WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE. BUT BUT THOSE CONCERNS
APPLY EQUALLY TO PRINTED MATTER.
CORRECT? RIGHT. WHICH MY
UNDERSTANDING IS MUCH OF IT IS
AVAILABLE FOR DISCLOSURE AND
SHARING WITH THE PUBLIC. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. I'VE I'VE
GOTTEN A BRIEFING FROM ONE OF
THE COMPANIES THAT OFFERS, YOU
KNOW, THIS APP BASED SERVICE.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THEIR THEIR
ASSERTION IS THAT THIS IS
THOROUGHLY PROTECTED, THAT IT
USES DATA FROM INSIDE, BUT IT
DOESN'T DISCLOSE THAT DATA TO
THE OUTSIDE BY WAY OF
IDENTIFYING WHERE A THREAT MIGHT
BE, OR MAPPING AND PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO FIRST RESPONDERS.
AND SO PRETTY CLEAR THAT IF YOU
IF YOU WROTE THAT DOWN, THAT'S
PROBABLY MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO A
PRIVACY BREACH THAN, YOU KNOW,
THAN DIGITALLY. SO I MEAN,
CLEARLY, I MEAN, THERE'S WORK TO
BE DONE HERE, BUT YOU KNOW, THE
PRIVACY CONCERNS ARE NOT UNIQUE
TO THE DIGITAL VERSION OF THIS.
CORRECT? OKAY. WELL, I GUESS
IT'S GOING TO BE UP TO THE
SENATE TO DO THE ASSEMBLY'S WORK
. YOU SAID THAT I, I DID NOT
YOU'RE DOING A FINE JOB, CORTEZ.
YOU HAD A QUESTION? YES, PLEASE.
YES. IT'S REALLY MORE OF A, A
SIMILAR COMMENT, I KNOW THAT THE
BECAUSE THE WORK I'VE DONE HERE
AND ALSO PRIOR IN MY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EXPERIENCE THAT THE
SCHOOL SAFETY PLANS ARE FILED
WITH THE STATE. YEAH. IN MARCH
THOSE PLANS THEMSELVES ARE SORT
OF BASICALLY, YOU KNOW,
NARRATIVE TYPES OF, OF PLANS.
THEY'RE NOT, YOU KNOW, SCHOOL
SITE DETAIL AS CALLED OUT IN
THIS BILL. SO I, I HAVE ALMOST
NO PROBLEM WITH PUTTING UP THE
SCHOOL SAFETY PLANS ON A PUBLIC
FACING WEB BASED, OR INTERNET
BASED, SITE. I DO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH, WITH
PUTTING UP DETAIL AROUND, YOU
KNOW, THAT WOULD SHOW THINGS
LIKE, YOU KNOW, WHERE SECURITY
CAMERAS ARE AND WHERE THEY'RE
NOT, YOU KNOW, WHERE POWER BOXES
ARE THAT CAN BE SHUT DOWN AND
WHERE THEY'RE NOT, ON A WEB
BASED, A WEB BASED, YOU KNOW,
PLATFORM, WHAT I THINK WOULD,
WOULD MAKE MORE SENSE TO ME. AND
YOU KNOW, MAYBE JUDICIAL FIGURE
THIS ALL OUT AS YOU'RE SAYING,
IS ON THAT KIND OF INFORMATION
TO HAVE, YOU KNOW, SOME KIND OF
SECURE DRIVE THAT IS DISTRIBUTED
OUT TO FIRST RESPONDERS. SO THEY
HAVE THAT INFORMATION. BUT SHORT
OF PUTTING IT ON A WEB BASED
PLATFORM, I THINK ONCE YOU DO
THAT, WE GET INTO A WHOLE BUNCH
OF OTHER ISSUES, INCLUDING, I
KNOW, SOMETHING THAT, OUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR UMBERG IS
QUITE FAMILIAR WITH, WHICH WHICH
IS FEDERAL SECTION 230, WHICH
THEN DISALLOWS YOU TO FILE ANY
KIND OF SUIT, IF THAT IF THAT
INFORMATION IS MOVED ALONG
SOMEWHERE, EITHER SHARED OR
HACKED OR UPLOADED OR
DOWNLOADED, THERE'S NO STATE
POSSIBLE STATE ACTION THAT YOU
COULD BRING TO HAVE IT REMOVED.
WE'VE SEEN IT WITH CSAM. WE'VE
SEEN IT WITH JUST ABOUT
EVERYTHING, THAT WE'VE TRIED TO
CREATE A STATE ACTION FOR IN
TERMS OF ADDRESSING, NEFARIOUS
ACTIVITIES THAT, YOU KNOW, MOVE
INFORMATION AROUND ON THE
INTERNET. SO I THINK HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL FIGURE IT OUT IF THEY
HAVEN'T FIGURED IT OUT BY THE
TIME AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT MY
COMMENT BOILS DOWN TO. YOU KNOW,
BY THE TIME IT GETS TO THE FOR
AND THAT PIECE IS STILL LEFT THE
WAY IT IS, RIGHT NOW, PRETTY
SURE I WOULD. I WOULD STAY OFF
OR VOTE NO ON THE FLOOR, BUT BUT
I DO LIKE THE REST OF THE PUBLIC
FACING INFORMATION BECAUSE I
THINK THOSE SCHOOL SAFETY PLANS
HAVE NOT BEEN DISSEMINATED VERY
WELL AMONG, YOU KNOW, THE
COMMUNITY, PARENTS, TEACHERS. SO
SO, SO WHAT'S REALLY INTERESTING
ABOUT THAT, AGAIN, BECAUSE THE
SCHOOL SHOOTING SO THE SCHOOL
SAFETY PLAN FOR SAUGUS HIGH
SCHOOL, 150 PAGES LONG, IT'S A
BOOK BECAUSE I PRINTED OUT
BECAUSE BUT THEY DRILL THEY,
THEY DO DRILLS ALL THE TIME. AND
WHEN THAT HAPPENED, THOSE KIDS,
IT WAS LIKE CLOCKWORK. IT WAS
REALLY AMAZING HOW THEY FILED
OUT. THEY WENT TO THE SAFE SPOT,
WHICH WAS A QUITE LARGE PARK
ACROSS THE STREET AND, AND, AND
THE, THE, CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WAS LIKE, LIKE,
THAT'S EXACTLY HOW YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO IT. SO THOSE
PLANS, I DON'T KNOW IF THEY MY
KIDS AREN'T IN SCHOOL ANYMORE,
BUT IF THEY GET DISTRIBUTED. BUT
THEY SHOULD. BUT THOSE STUDENTS
ARE DRILLED ON WHAT ON WHAT TO
DO AND NOT TO DO. TRUE. AND IT
SAVES LIVES. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. SENATOR CORTEZ, YOU
KNOW, IN THE ABSENCE OF THE
AUTHOR, YOU KNOW, WE'RE TO YOUR
POINT. IT WOULD PROBABLY HAVE TO
WORK THESE ISSUES THROUGH,
HOPEFULLY WITH THE AUTHOR. AND
I'M ON JUDICIARY AS WELL. SO
APPRECIATE THAT VICE CHAIR. I
WILL SAY, YOU KNOW, THE ANALYSIS
NOTES THAT THAT THE FEAR OF
SCHOOL SHOOTINGS IS A REAL
THING. AND I WAS, A PARTICIPANT
IN A CAREER DAY AT MY KIDS
SCHOOL RECENTLY. AND I WAS
STRUCK AS I GOT INTO THE LATER
GRADES, FIFTH, SIXTH, SEVENTH,
EIGHTH GRADE. THAT WAS THE ONE
THING THAT KIDS WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT. THEIR FEAR OF, OF
SHOOTINGS, FEAR OF ON CAMPUS
SCHOOL SHOOTERS, AND GIVING THEM
THE ASSURANCE THAT THERE IS A
PROGRAM AND A RESPONSE PROCESS
IN PLACE. IT'S PROBABLY REALLY
IMPORTANT. OH, ABSOLUTELY. SO I
WAS, I WAS AT A RURAL ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL, I THINK FOURTH GRADE,
BECAUSE THAT'S WHEN THEY LEARNED
ABOUT CALIFORNIA HISTORY TO, TO
SPEAK. AND I ASKED THEM WHAT
WHAT WHAT LAW WOULD YOU LIKE ME
TO INTRODUCE? AND A LITTLE GIRL
SAID, WE NEED METAL DETECTORS AT
OUR SCHOOL. SO I FEEL SAFE. AND
THIS IS LIKE OUT IN THE MIDDLE
OF NOWHERE. YEAH. SO IT'S
PREVALENT AND IT'S EVERYWHERE.
AND WE NEED TO DO ALL WE CAN TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF OUR
CHILDREN. I APPRECIATE THAT. SO
WE HAVE A MOTION OR DO WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM SENATOR GLASER, I
BELIEVE NO, IT WASN'T GLASER.
SENATOR SCHMOKE RIVAS DID YOU
MAKE THE MOTION? NO, NO, WE
DON'T. I'LL MOVE IT AS A
COURTESY. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR
CORTEZ MOVES THE BILL. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER? DON'T LEAVE ME
HANGING OUT TO DRY WITH
ASSEMBLYMAN MATHIS KILLED IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE. YOU'RE GOING TO
KILL IT. NO ON. I MEAN, I KNOW I
LOOK AT WE ALL ARE LOOKING TO DO
WHAT'S RIGHT FOR OUR STUDENTS.
SURELY THIS NEEDS MORE WORK. I
PLEDGE TO YOU THAT I'LL MAKE
SURE THAT, THAT THE ASSEMBLYMAN
GETS THAT DONE FOR YOU. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE WE HAVE
A MOTION FROM SENATOR CORTEZ.
MR. HORNER, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY, MADAM CONSULTANT,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FOR ITEM
THREE, AB 960. MATHIS THE MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
NEWMAN. A NEWMAN. AYE. JONES.
JONES. AYE. CORTEZ A CORTEZ I.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. SIX VOTES. AND IT IS
OUT, SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
THANK YOU AGAIN, LET'S GO BACK
TO, THE FIRST ITEM ON THE AGENDA
AND. HOW ARE WE GOING TO DO IT?
LET'S START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR, WE'RE GOING TO REOPEN
THE ROLL ON CONSENT, AND, MADAM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE PROCEED ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. GLAZER
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE. WILK AYE. WILK. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT.
SEVEN VOTES TO ZERO, NEXT ITEM,
PLEASE FILE ITEM NINE, AB 2033.
REYES MOTION IS DUE PASSED. THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLAZER GLAZER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. WILK WILK. AYE.
THAT MEASURE IS AT SEVEN VOTES
TO ZERO. NEXT, PLEASE FILE ITEM
TEN AB 2046. BRIAN. MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. CURRENT
VOTE IS TWO A'S AND ONE NØ, WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE AND THE
VICE CHAIR VOTING NO. GLAZER
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. WILK ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURE IS OUT. FIVE
VOTES TO 1655. SORRY. NEXT A
FILE ITEM 12 AB 2137
QUIRK-SILVA. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND NO
NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. WILK. WILK. AYE. THAT
MEASURE IS OUT. SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. NEXT, PLEASE. ITEM 13 AB
2076 MCCARTY. MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE EYES AND
NO NOES. JONES. GLASER GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. AYE. THAT MEASURE IS
THAT. SIX VOTES TO ZERO. NEXT,
PLEASE. ITEM 19 AB 2377 THREE OF
US MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EYES AND NO
NO'S WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE AND THAT
MEASURES OUT SEVEN VOTES TO
ZERO. AND LAST ITEM. ITEM 24 AB
3223. WILSON MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
EYES AND NO NO'S WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
GLASER. GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT MEASURES OUT SEVEN
VOTES TO ZERO, THAT CLOSES THE
ROLL. THAT COMPLETES OUR HEARING
FOR TODAY, THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION IS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO STAFF AND TO THE SERGEANTS.